es la tumba de un faraón más conservada
que se haya encontrado y continúa siendo
una de las atracciones más populares en
el mundo en el corazón del Valle de Los
Reyes La tumba de Tutankamón ha
fascinado a Los visitantes por un siglo
excavadores encabezados por el
arqueólogo inglés Howard Carter la
descubrieron en noviembre de 1922
revelando primero unos escalones luego
una puerta un antesala y después de más
de un año de escarbar llegaron a un
segundo nivel que los condujo a una
tumba
se pueden imaginar la sorpresa cuando
deslizaron una lámpara en el hoyo y en
su luz parpadeante pudieron distinguir
una habitación llena de objetos uno más
hermoso que el otro todo en un desorden
total
cerca de 5.500 piezas invaluables se
apilaron en torno al sarcófago del joven
faraón más de 30 siglos atrás para
acompañarlo después de la muerte
Los arqueólogos quedaron cautivados por
la máscara de oro de 10 kilos El faraón
para desgracia de la momia
[Música]
asombrado por la belleza de la máscara
Howard Carter se esperó en quitarse la
de encima a la momia y en el proceso
destruyó su cráneo
pocos meses después el descubrimiento el
financista de las excavaciones de cárter
murió en El Cairo le siguió la muerte de
un hombre de negocios que había visitado
la tumba y de un radiólogo que había
examinado la momia las noticias
alimentaron la Superstición de que
Tutankamón se estaba vengando de los que
perturbaron el lugar de su entierro la
maldición de los faraones Cien años
después su rostro sigue siendo el más
emblemático del Antiguo Egipto pero los
arqueólogos aún esperan encontrar a
Ramsés octavo el único faraón de la
vigésima dinastía cuya tumba no ha sido
identificada
el sueño de todo arqueólogo descubrir
más tesoros ocultos tan preciosos como
los de Tutankamón